hello everyone and welcome to another
most impressive game uh from the second
day of the quarterfinals of the ancient
u.s rapid knockouts it's already versus
wesley so and uh sorry this is not from
the second day this is from the tie
breaks as you know alireza won the first
match then wesley retaliated in the
second match and now this is the tie
breaks in tie breaks we are no longer in
rapid uh we are playing blitz chess five
minutes plus three seconds increment and
this is game two of their match so uh
two games are played and then if both
games end in a draw or you know if each
player wins one then we go into
armageddon so in the first game where
wesley had the white pieces the game
ended in a draw
now uh wesley has the black pieces and
let's see what happened here so furuja
with the white pieces opens with e4 uh
with e5 by wesley knight f3 knight to f6
going for the petrov's defense uh and
knight captures an e5 we have d6
challenging the knight so this is the
classical variation of the petrov and
knight back to f3 in his younger days
alireza would probably go for knight
captures on f7 and a lot of strong
players have played it uh which had some
very very impressive results with this
um
early sacrifice because you do get two
pawns
but here we have knight to f3 it would
be yeah maybe a bit suicidal to try this
against wesley uh knight captures on e4
and now there are again a lot of
possible moves here knight the c 3d for
queen e2 all very good ideas but here we
have bishop to d3 and it seems kind of
weird placing your bishop like this so
you can't develop your d-pawn but white
has plans in the future in the future
the bishop will either retreat to e2 or
you can maybe play c3 bishop c2 or
you're just gonna capture the knight uh
you know just trade on e4 and that's how
you're gonna get your uh sword deep one
up the board uh so here we have d5 by
wesley defending the knight and now
queen e2 attacking the knight one more
time so uh wesley defense queen to e7
and here alireza just castles we have
knight back to d6 wesley offers a queen
trade and alireza declines it he goes
back queen to d1 now the rook is coming
to e1 so wesley also moves his queen
back so queen back to d8 we have rook to
e1 check bishop to e7 and now knight to
c3 for the moment black can't really
castle because the d5 pawn is hanging so
c6 defending this pawn and now uh there
are a couple of games where queen to e2
was played just putting pressure on the
bishop here not allowing this uh king to
just castle freely but here uh we have
b3 and it is now only as of movie 11
that we have a completely new game so
let's see how wesley continues we have
castles and now bishop to a3 uh putting
more pressure uh here on black's
position if the knight now moves you're
going to lose this bishop here so bishop
to g4 pinning the knight here and now h3
challenging this bishop we have bishop
to h5 and now queen to e2 attacking the
bishop on e7
and here's a moment where you could
easily go wrong rook to e8 seems like a
perfectly normal move just aligning the
rook with the queen getting the rook
away from the f8 square but it doesn't
really work because here white has queen
to e5 and there's a problem now your
bishop is hanging and also bishop
captures on d6 bishop captures queen
characters here could
be be very bad for black so here you
don't really have anything better than
bishop captures on f3 and after bishop
captures on d6 we go into this forced
line knight to d7 you have to connect
your rooks uh and now bishop captures on
e7 knight captures on e5 bishop capture
78 rook a capture 78 and now you're
gonna give up uh the rook for two pieces
rook captures rook characters and of
course g captures an f3 and after uh all
is said and done a white will have two
pieces for the rook uh and enjoy a a
better game so wesley of course after
queen to e2 does not go wrong he plays
bishop to f6 just gets his dark square
bishop out of harm's way and now queen
to e3 a lot of moves with with the queen
from alireza with rook to e8 now
attacking the queen and queen to f4 now
with
a double attack on this knight here and
here uh a very very critical moment
wesley has to play knight to e4 it's
upon sacrifice but you have to do it uh
and we would see something like bishop
captures the captures we're going to see
rook captures rook characters knight
captures and the game now oh sorry not
knight captures queen captures and the
game now continues we don't want to
blunder blunder our rook uh so this is
probably what's what's best for for
black continuing with knight a6 and then
trying to develop the knight this way
however wesley played rook capture sunny
one and again it seems like such a
normal move but it loses the game such
you know such is the way of chess
so alireza of course captures back
there's no nothing better we have rook
captures on e1 and now wesley's knight
is still hanging so you have to move it
you can't really defend it if you play
something like bishop to e7 we again try
queen e5 with a double attack here and
after bishop to f8 uh trying to you know
save one of the the bishops if you try
bishop captures on f3 it's really not
much better just queen captures on e7
and again your bishop is hanging and
your queen is hanging so let's say
captures captures and you can't save the
bishop because well then the knight is
hanging so everything is hanging here so
you'd have to try some like bishop to f8
but then we of course uh just check made
the black king bishop captures on h7
king captures queen captures on h5 king
j8 and ig5 uh we're gonna now checkmate
the black king
so after this uh rook captures on e1
wesley plays the only move left for
black that is knight to e8 but now comes
the idea that uh well uh it seems like
uh alireza had it prepared uh before the
game i could be wrong but it seems like
you know such a powerful uh opening idea
and you know just uh completely
annihilating your opponent uh
without much trouble as it would seem uh
i think he was prepared like i said i
could be wrong but feel free to pause
the video and try to find this idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that i
don't know how do you even spot this
that the f8 square is available for the
white queen that's that's the good stuff
by bringing the knight to e8 wesley uh
disconnected the queen's defense of the
f8 square and now alireza plays g4 now
you could play queen to b4 right away
but g4 is the more precise idea so if
you found this you are obviously you
obviously should be rated at least 2700
so here bishop to g6 you have nothing
better here all it is adjust trades
captures captures and now queen to b4
and now there's a problem the b7 pawn is
hanging but also queen to f8 check
followed by rook captures here is coming
so what can westley do the only move is
knight to d7 we have to defend this
square and we have to give up this pawn
uh you know two of the lesser evils
queen captures on b7 now attacking the
c6 pawn and wesley just defends it and
now knight to a4 so now we're having
very nice control of the c5 square and
if the knight moves then we're just
going to play star knight and c5 and
we're just going to have a much better
position being up material and
you don't have a good good move here
with black to give you an example if you
try something like g5 which makes sense
as white wants to push g5 himself at
some point we would see bishop b4 going
for bishop to a5 and now let's say
knight b6 uh knight to c5 this is now
just uh just a beautifully placed knight
and after knight to d6 attacking the
white queen queen back to a6 now we can
shift the the the queen back we can do
pretty much anything but we're just
better and uh well this is one way to do
it wesley doesn't like this wesley wants
to activate his position he plays knight
to c7 and he starts sacrificing even
more pawns we have queen captures on c6
now comes knight to e6 opening up a
discovery here queen captures on the e5
and now rook captures on c2 so here
wesley is down two points but he has a
very active rook and he's gonna collect
at least one more pawn so here bishop
back to d6 the the bishop will come
under attack after the rook captures an
a2 but now
wesley does not capture an a2 first he
plays knight d to c5
now saying that okay the bishop cannot
capture because your queen on d5 is
undefended uh and alireza doesn't want
to trade or you know just allow wesley
to activate his pieces so he brings the
knight back knight to c3 and now the
rook can't really do anything so uh
wesley has to give up his dark square
bishop to weaken some pawns so here we
have bishop captures on c3 d captures on
c3 and now uh wesley doesn't uh doesn't
uh
you know want to capture a pawn here uh
you could play rook captures on c3 and
although white is still better uh white
would have to uh really figure out how
to go about this position rook to d1 is
the one such idea bringing the knight to
e5 and then uh you know continuing with
rook to d1 also an idea but here uh
instead of this rook capture wesley
played knight to f4 it's a straight out
uh
sacrifice the knight here is hanging uh
you can't capture with the bishop you
have to capture with the queen but he
wants to play knight captures an h3 with
check and then also pick up the f2 pawn
and if possible even the g3 pawn so this
is definitely worth a knight on c5 so
alireza accepts this we have queen
captures on c5 knight captures an h3
with check we've reached the position
from the thumbnail king to g2 and now
knight captures an f2 not only going for
the for the pawn here uh you could
capture uh with the rook but then the
knight just hangs so here knight
captures an f2 now threatening some very
nasty discoveries like knight here with
czech will pick up the queen so king to
g3 stepping out of the discovery and
also guarding against knight captures on
g4 and now wesley brings the queen into
the attack queen to d7 now hones in on
that g for g4 pawn
and alireza defends it just queen to d4
and now uh wesley has to figure out how
to continue this attack otherwise he's
just down material and it's not gonna be
it's not gonna be good and if he loses
this game it's alireza who's off to the
semifinals so queen to c6 now putting
pressure on this pawn here there's
really nothing better here but bishop
back to f4 and now the problem is wesley
can't even capture this pawn because if
rook captures then the knight hangs and
if you try queen captures on c3 you get
checkmated queen to d8 check king h7 now
queen to h for check king has to go to
g8 and the rook to e8 will of course be
checkmate so after bishop to f4 uh
wesley brought the queen back with queen
to c8 again going for that g4 pawn but
now alireza takes care of this threat by
introducing a terrible threat and that
is bishop to d2 so now the queen guards
against this queen captures on g4 idea
and also the rook's defense of the
knight is now disconnected there's
nothing for for black to do here uh the
knight is trapped you can't save it and
that's it it was in this position on
move 33 that wesley so resigned the game
and with it uh his uh
uh
well adjusted the match so uh took to
caliresa a lot like i said he won the
first match lost the second one and then
it took tie breaks to to beat wesley but
he is now in the semi-finals and here
are the uh this the current standings as
you can see ferruja will face vladislav
in the semi-finals uh and the magnus
will face levon arunyan so we're gonna
have a very very very enjoyable day
uh so yeah there we have it uh that's
the game i hope you guys enjoyed it
really uh a wonderful one and it's
really awesome how how early you can go
wrong uh i mean alireza just prepared
this uh
extremely well
uh so once again hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank hayden queenie
aditya parasarati uh christopher
alexander sopa tom derelo and
cakedefy.com for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh with this contribution
kkd5.com becomes the top contributor to
the channel uh and as they say on their
website you on their website you can do
some liquidity mining staking lending uh
but also just put your cryptocurrencies
to work uh so there you have it uh as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day